welcome back to las vegas now the
southwest medical hospice scare the
sponsors of this segment provide the
right care at the right time and with
the right companion
my name is sue grundfest i'm the founder
and president of pet partners of las
vegas which is the nevada affiliate of
the national pet partners animal
assisted intervention program and i've
been in las vegas for 14 years from new
york i started doing animal assisted
therapy in new york and came here and
brought our program to las vegas this is
benny he's one of my several therapy
dogs and he's awesome benny is a senior
he's been working for 12 years he works
in two schools with special needs
children he works with teens at risk and
mental health in
behavioral situations he does work a lot
that is his favorite thing when i take
out the vest and his golden knights
leash that he only wears when he works
he perks up wags his tail comes running
that's his best medicine that he gets to
go out and you saw he loves to hug so
that's his favorite thing giving hugs
and if he could not work i think his
life would be a lot less
valuable to him
he wants to see the cameraman now see
what do you think
i've worked with hospice over the years
many times but when southwest called me
it was during covet and that was a time
we had agreed we would not take on any
new commitments but when i spoke with
them and really learned more about them
i understood that they were very much
like pet partners they believed in
exquisite training of their volunteers
taking care of their volunteers and
their clients and we knew it would be a
good fit so that was the only group we
took on in the last two years
we're privileged to enter somebody's
life at a hard time and if we can bring
them a little bit of peace in that time
it's worth it hospice is even above that
we are seeing people at a time sensitive
time
i don't know if that client i'll ever
see again so that time we spend together
i feel privileged that they've given me
that small window of time
when who knows how much time they have
and and
it's not for everyone we know that and
you don't have to have a pet
southwest medical has volunteers doing
all kinds of other roles but it is a
very special
invitation into someone's life
when perhaps it is measured
and forget our client is not just that
patient it's the family members we give
them a little respite we give them a
break they're happy to see benny you
know that tuesday is very important to
them because they get a break
so i think that the partnership with
southwest pet partners could not be any
more divine you want to know that it's
good to get out of yourself sometimes
and even if you're having a really
stressed day what will help me
decompress or de-stress is i'm thinking
of someone else i'm sharing my dog with
them
we get to feel
present
and that's hard in today's world
especially the last few years so having
that sense of presence with someone
someone new i like hearing your new
stories we've been told by one client
that that particular family member that
is the hospice client of southwest
is never perky except the day benny
comes
and she will sing to him she knows the
songs the lyrics to one song
and she sings it to him every visit
and it's the highlight of my day
and you like it too
thank you to southwest medical hospice
care for sponsoring this segment call
702 671
or visit the website on your screen for
more information
[Music]